today on stick to football eight is mock
draft Monday time Connor and I are gonna
rip through the entire first round of
the 2020 NFL Draft but we have to talk
about our guy to ax and the injury that
happened to him on Saturday that is the
big news of the weekend as it affects
the draft so we're gonna dive in deep
onto a what his future is what this does
to the draft class but first couple
reminders this Saturday November 22nd we
will be at the Stanford Cal game
tailgating right there on the Grove
we've tweeted out the map if you want to
find it right off El Camino real easy
easy spot to find and we'll have a huge
tent Mel O'Connor and I'll be there
recording the podcast having fun like we
always do and then December 7th we will
be at the SEC championship game right
outside the mercedes-benz Superdome
Johnsonville tailgate throwdown they're
gonna have like cooking competitions
cornhole tournaments Connors gonna be a
great time I'm very excited for what
might be the last two tailgates tops of
the year it's gonna be awesome obviously
we haven't been to Stanford yet so
really excited for our West Coast Swing
of the year it seems like we have a
really good set up out there Matt as
well when I was looking at the tailgate
guys map for that one so that's gonna be
awesome and then when you look at the
SEC Championship if you're down south
you're anywhere near the Atlanta area I
don't think you'll want to miss this
because we have an awesome guest lined
up and Sean Alexander there's gonna be
some crazy cook-off that I think Melo is
officially going to be judging it and a
lot of other people professional
cornhole players it's just going to be
absolute madness with Johnsonville so
we're really excited for that but
speaking of the SEC the championship
game the cook-off that stuff's all fun
what wasn't fun was this weekend when
two atong of Aloha gets injured again
but this time in the most serious
fashion with a significant hip injury
Matt let's just start with the latest
here and the situation for him what is
the latest out of the people you've
talked to you of the impact of this
significant injury yeah I will say I
mean it's it's gut-wrenching I was at
another game as were you this weekend
and so you get the alert and you watch
the video and you're just your heart
sinks a little bit and you
like I've said with the Jaylon Smith
injury you you want to throw up because
you feel so badly for the player so what
- I will say this he has a very small
insular circle of people so this isn't
like it you know of another player where
to get hurt it's easy - sometimes you
have a direct line to the player to the
parents to an agent to the school - is a
little different and I think that's a
good thing for him today he's having
surgery in Houston Monday he's having
surgery in Houston to try to repair you
know the hip dislocation the fracture of
the outside wall of his hip it's bad and
what I was told Sunday night was no one
knows yet how bad it could be he'll
never play football again or it could be
you know he could be playing late 2020
so everyone is kind of on a wait-and-see
until he gets out of the surgery I know
they came out and said over the weekend
we expect a full recovery I was told I
don't necessarily believe that because
they really have to get in and see how
bad the damage was as far as the surgery
goes now as far as the 2020 NFL Draft
where is the mindset the family has been
talking like okay there's no reason for
him to go back to Alabama at this point
basically they did have an insurance
policy I'm told so if he falls in the
draft and that would be expected that he
would he can recoup some of that money
you know with Jalen Smith it was if he
falls through the second round he's
gonna get a couple million dollars
because of these insurance policies I'm
told - it did have one so it does not
benefit him to go back to Alabama
because he would forfeit that insurance
money so really this is set up for him
to declare for the draft to rehab
probably at Alabama over the next couple
months declare for the draft he's
obviously not gonna be able to do the
combine he's I'm gonna do a pro day but
I think the belief is that he could then
get drafted like a Jaylon Smith rehab
with the team he's gonna be able to
collect that insurance money if he falls
far enough in the draft so it's really
it's a tough situation but there were
some safeguards in place so I tweeted
this over the weekend it's like I don't
want to speculate until I can talk to
people and I'm not gonna speculate about
when he's gonna go to play again but I
will tell you the belief at Alabama
right now is that he will still enter
the 2020 draft now where he gets picked
he's open to a lot of interpretation
because you got to see the severity of
the end
and I'll tell you in Conor you've been
doing this a little bit of time as well
you know every team is gonna have a
different opinion based on what they're
dr. Wilson and I've been in meetings
with with GM's and asking them about
players and they'd say I don't know it
depends on what our doctor tells us I
Jaylon Smith and I had a really good
relationship and there were a lot of
teams I called on for him and his agent
saying word where's he gonna get picked
and they'd say that's not up to me it's
up to the doctor like we have a talent
great on this guy but the injury grade
is such-and-such
and there weren't many teams that were
willing to draft him with to it we could
be looking at a similar situation but I
think it's irresponsible if you hear
anyone get on TV podcast Twitter and say
this does x2 to his draft stock no one
knows that right now so I don't even
think we should play that game of oh
he's gonna fall five spots or he's gonna
go undrafted or it's all just
speculation at this point there's not
enough information to make a really good
educated guess yeah I mean he could
still go in the top three he could fall
out of the first round that's the kind
of spectrum you're dealing with here now
what I will say is Matt for tua and
obviously you know we're hoping that he
does make a full recovery because you
and I have both had both believed for a
while that he was the best quarterback
in this class and just that injuries are
really the only concern talent character
leadership all those things he was an
a-plus in all of them truly it truly was
and truly still is that's the most
important thing to note here and that
listen this could end up a situation
where one team ends up becoming
extremely fortunate and it's it's awful
to see that two of my slide but it might
end up being a great thing for another
team if he does if he does make that
full recovery so it does change the
draft and this is a draft podcast it is
it has always been and always will be
that's the most important thing and we
do at some point need to discuss the
trickle effect of this because you have
a team like the Bengals expected to pick
first overall you have the Dolphins that
are dead set on looking for a
quarterback you have a lot of teams that
are looking for a quarterback getting
away from the component of just hey to a
might not be a number one or number two
overall pick anymore we don't know what
is the now the pivot for those teams
if they have to make one well you hate
to to phrase it this way about I don't
know any other way to phrase it this is
good news for Justin Herbert because we
do this before it's going to push him up
where and I we've been talking about
Justin Harper for a couple weeks and
telling you like we might not love him
but there's a lot of like out there for
him as a top ten pick this could get
Justin Herbert within the top five picks
just depending on what teams do but this
has a massive ripple effect on not so
much the Cincinnati Bengals right now
would have the number one pick I assume
they would draft Justin Herbert Ryan
Finley looks bad again on Sunday it
seems like they would take the local guy
Justin her or excuse me the local guy
and Joe borough and move on but where
this gets interesting is you know the
Miami Dolphins have actually been
winning a couple games they're gonna be
picking at four and we're gonna discuss
this in our mock chef Monday but you
know so for the Dolphins if you and the
rumor was that they'd like zeroed in on
tua
this could completely change your
strategy of what is it what is our
quarterback moving forward if you're the
Bucs
and you're still not sure what you're
doing with Jameis Winston the
quarterback availability the market just
got a lot weaker because one guy who was
gonna be a top three or four pick is now
off that market so if you're Tampa if
you're Tennessee if you're the Chargers
and we're thinking about a future after
Philip Rivers who's a free agent than
Orleans Saints Teddy Bridgewater and
Drew Brees are free agents and there's a
lot of teams out there that either have
a dire need at quarterback like right
now they need a 2020 guy or the teams
that wanted to start drafting a head I
think I mean Justin harbors gonna get
pushed up we could see Jacob East and
get pushed up Jordan Love who has had a
bad year at Utah State but as a trait
sky could get pushed back up Jake from
who has not been super productive at
Georgia but has been good his name could
get floated back into this situation
I've had family members start reaching
out about quarterbacks that I would have
never thought we're gonna enter the 2020
draft now they're reaching out being
like hey what should we do because of
this situation and I'm telling everybody
the same thing we have to wait and see
but I can tell you four days ago I
didn't think your son should enter the
NFL Draft so I don't know that he I
don't know that he should now like if
you're a late rounder this isn't gonna
automatically push you up into the
second round or anything but there is
gonna be a reshuffling until much more
is known about - and unfortunately he's
gonna be a while I think I mean some
clarity will come out post-surgery but
for the most part with these things
you're gonna have to wait and see you
know a couple months down the road where
is he at in terms of his rehab I think
the one guy for me that the
decision-making might change or should
change it's not someone like Jalen Hertz
even though obviously he's in this class
but it's not Sam Ehlinger it's shake
from for me I think Jake Fromm is the
quarterback that can enter this draft
and the conversation around Jake Fromm
has been hey probably second round just
lacks the physical traits but he's a
smart guy that can win you football
games I think Jake Fromm is the guy that
can see the jump into the back end of
round one because of this in the long
run yeah I mean like I said the Saints
are sitting right there they're gonna
have a late round one pick depending on
what happens in the playoffs and they
could even if they bring back Teddy they
could be thinking about a quarterback to
the Future Jake from so this is a good
opportunity and as you know one of my
favorite sayings is quarterback scouting
often starts in January because it's so
much the mental or the leadership the
interviews all the off field Jake
Fromm's gonna he's gonna nail all that
so if he can convince the team that his
lack of arm strength of physical tools
isn't a massive liability and man in the
NFL watching games yesterday arm
strength is still like it's nice to have
but I'll tell you it is not a huge need
because so many of these teams like the
balls just coming out quick and it's
going horizontal so Jake Fromm might fit
in better in the NFL than we've been
giving him credit for it is mock draft
Monday time these Cincinnati Bengals
remain winless so they are on the clock
Connor Rodgers you are general manager
take it away buddy well thanks for
giving me the first overall pick here
Matt because this is the easiest one
I'll have to make today the Bengals
they're probably taking Joe Barrow first
overall here anything else would really
surprise me I just think listen are
there questions about Joe Barroso of
course he's not perfect he's not Andrew
Luck but for this Cincinnati team to get
in a former Ohio you know face of the
state kind of player a guy that's
absolutely tore up the college football
world this year they needed a new face
of the franchise for Zach Taylor this
pick will be Joe burrow oh and 10 the
Bengals are I don't know if they'll win
a game I really don't know again not by
design they're gentlemen they want to
anymore with
Finley's out there right at this point
you're just like yeah let's just lose
number to the Washington Redskins oh
they are bad we see Dwayne Haskins
pleading - his offensive line to block
for him they felt bad for him man I
actually do - I liked him a decent
amount and it just seems like an awful
situation for him so they drop
everything they don't block he's sure
he's trying to learn while getting hit
and having to deal with drops on his
actual good throws it's tough out there
yeah and if two were healthy we might
talk about him here but he's not so
Washington hopefully does the smart
thing and I will say their drafts are
pretty much chalk they go with best
player available its chase young and
there's really no other conversation I
know they draft a montes wet high last
year I know that Ryan Kerrigan neither
of those guys matter in this situation
because chase young is that good of a
prospect he is hands-down the best
player in the 2020 trap so if he's here
team if they're gonna stick by their
quarterback you have to take chase young
having too many pass rushers that's
there's no such thing as too many pass
rushers watch us what really hasn't been
that great this year Ryan Kerrigan
Carrigan's getting older chase young is
a an absolute no-brainer at number two
easily I mean Kerrigan will be 32 next
year and you can get out of his deal
completely free and save almost 12
million dollars on the cap so I think
that's a no-brainer in this spot for
Washington number three the New York
Giants I don't think this is a Dave
gentlemen pick in this spot I took Jerry
Judy I don't think that's a very good
omen pick a wide receiver at three I
think he wants to build this offensive
line to prove everyone he was right
about Daniel Jones I can't argue with
that strategy the problem is Matt I
don't have a no line at three that makes
sense for the right here I don't I don't
I can't pass on Judy get Daniel Jones a
weapon I spent some time with Darius
Slaton this weekend who's had a really
really awesome season he had nothing but
great things to say about his rapport
with Daniel Jones and what they're
building over there but I still think
they could use a star wide receiver
across from him for this offense yet not
a gentleman picked that's a semi pick
man take the receiver early still love
Jerry Judy he slipped down to number
three or disagreeing with Dave gentlemen
usually is a smart thing to do right
yeah I'm actually hitting like a
thousand I'm in my little career arguing
with him number four the Miami Dolphins
this is where we've had
- etana bi-lo going forever it seems
like but his injury opens the door for
Justin Herbert to be the pick here again
not a quarterback that I absolutely love
but Herbert has been playing very well
lately he made a couple throws against
Arizona that I'm it that made me put my
pin down and then I remembered he was
playing Arizona and they are really
really bad especially in the secondary
but the throws the throw Herbert did
look really good Saturday night and he's
been on a roll this year the production
has been fantastic they've only lost one
game I do think that Herbert as long as
the interviews okay and handles that
side of business teams are gonna fall in
love with the dude that's six foot five
240 pounds can move and has a really big
right arm
yeah he's quietly starting to really
really pick it up the only question is
can he bring that Oregon offensive line
with him to Miami in the next five years
but number five my New York Jets listen
this isn't a Joe Douglas papal once
again I don't give a [ __ ] because this
is our mock your Afton we get to do what
we want
I took C D lamb here I can make the
argument for Jeff Okuda and Andrew
Thomas but I feel like I make the
argument for both of them every single
mock draft Monday we do so let's have
some fun let's switch it up I think C D
lamb will finish as a top five top ten
player for me in this class it just
doesn't look like they're making Robby
Anderson a focal point of this offense
so they're probably gonna have him walk
in free agency they love Jameson Crowder
there they love getting the tight ends
involved Quincy in noon whoa we don't
know if he's gonna play again and
there's a lot of friction with the team
that all those things mean one thing the
Jets need a number one wide receiver
that can play on the outside that's C D
lamb yeah I like C to lamb a lot like
you said he's that number seven or eight
overall on my board right now and he's
not gonna run well let's just set that
expectation in any rate it's not a Joe
Douglas pick but we've seen the last two
games some pretty good flashes from Sam
Donald and I think it's time to continue
to build around him some of the last
regime really didn't do especially with
early picks but there's no offensive
lineman to draft here so the next best
thing you already got a running back get
your due to number one receiver that he
can grow with on the job a little bit
number six the Tampa Bay Buccaneers just
cut Vernon Hargreaves let's replace him
because Corner is a massive need on this
team I'll take a Jeff Okuda here corner
from Ohio State I absolutely love accout
I think he's close to flawless as a
prospect you might be wondering why no
quarterback here this is one of the
effects of the two
injury I can see Tampa giving Jameis
Winston a one to two year deal to see if
he can continue to develop underneath
Bruce Arians to where they can get him
to you know medium lever's level starter
quality and try to build the team around
him
Ariane's has been at times very
supportive of Jameis at other times he
has said things like well he has to keep
playing like he did for the rest of the
year for us to keep it's a thing about
keeping him so I think it's very much up
in the air what Tampa does at
quarterback if they drafted one I think
Herbert fits their scheme the best with
him off the board for me it's Jeff Okuda
yeah hard to argue there CUDA is a great
player and probably at the end of the
day we'll go earlier than sixth overall
number seven the Denver Broncos I think
they need a lot of help at tackle this
team
they really do they're gonna have a
change at quarterback next year it's
probably gonna be drew locks time to
shine we'll see unless they sign someone
John Elway goes through quarterbacks
quicker than anyone
but for me it's Andrew Thomas in this
spot I still haven't as the top
offensive lineman in this class and I
think he'd be a plug and play starter
for Denver out there yep absolutely love
that big need for them the Falcons at
number eight this is a tough team to
draft for but I really like Derek Brown
the defensive lineman from Auburn Melo
and I watching him play Saturday Connor
you get to watch him up close the dudes
just ease a freak I mean he is so agile
for how big he is and I don't know how
they're listing him at 315 pounds cuz he
looks 330 but my goodness he can move
around and make some really really good
plays so I like him they I don't know
what the falcons are gonna do where
they're gonna be I mean they're winning
now the defense looks absolutely nasty
again they're glass now right it's like
they just needed to hit the halfway
point be like oh [ __ ] we better start
playing and they have been playing
really well and they're coming together
I think if you throw a defensive tackle
like Derek Brown what they have up front
with Grady Jarrett just put those two
guys together and I don't think anyone
could block them so that's where I go
here all right number nine in the
Arizona Cardinals Kliff Kingsbury pretty
good start to his coaching career I know
they lost a tough one to San Francisco
but at least they look capable out there
they look a lot more capable than I
expected
Kyler Murray's starting to really really
turn on he's quietly had a very nice
rookie season this is an offense that
will always look for a vertical threat
or even a threat that can catch those
horizontal passes that you talked about
earlier Matt where there
screens it maybe even jet sweeps the
touch passes the pitch passes Henry rugs
is your guy for that mr. four to five
kind of speed henry rugs and Kliff
Kingsbury offense would be a lot of fun
to watch and his pretty good fit at
number nine overall not fair is what
that would be
just all the ways they could find to get
him the ball it would be very exciting
number ten the detroit lions this the
board didn't fall great for them here i
just be honest but I do think the right
side of the line I don't leer icky
Wagner's getting the job done Tristan
works from Iowa plays right tackle there
I think he could play right or left in
the NFL just move him right up the
highway get him into with the Detroit
Lions because they need someone like
this the lines and other team like
they're playing better than their record
and trying to find like oh gosh they
need like they really need another pass
rusher they could use I think a little
bit of an upgrade in the secondary none
of neither of those spots for me made
sense with with the way the board fell
so I'm gonna go right tackle try to
solidify what they have in front of
Matthew Stafford number eleven
Jacksonville Jaguars this is a team that
has some needs in the trenches I would
more specifically a look at offensive
line but with worse off the board there
no value here yet I go jewbot and Kinlaw
he has been a beast this year we loved
having him on the show and I just think
he keeps getting better and better
I really do to the point where he's
probably gonna be a top 15 pick you look
at the size six six three ten productive
already sixaxis year for an interior
lineman Kinlaw listen clays Campbell
still has it but at some point you got
to think about this defensive line I
don't know what's Haven Brian is yet I
like the value of Kinlaw in this spot
for Jacksonville yeah I do as well
number 12 the Los Angeles chargers this
is where I'm gonna take to Otunga by
Lowell and here's what I think can
happen I think they can sign Phillip
Rivers to a one or two year deal because
I don't think he's ready to quit playing
even though there's been some struggles
this year sign rivers to one or two year
deal and Rivers has been not so quiet
about saying he does not want to mentor
someone well he went half to because you
put two on IR for 2020 let him rehab let
him learn let him work his way back and
then 2021 Rivers can retire or go play
for the Titans get back close to where
he wants to be in Alabama and to it can
be the starting quarterback for the
Chargers now this is all contingent on
health and I understand the irony of
giving a banged up quarter
to a team that is tragically chronically
injured in the Los Angeles Chargers but
they need a spark there as well as the
future playing at quarterback and I
think if they can slow play it with - uh
you're getting a great value at 12
overall yeah they really do that would
be an awesome plan and I actually really
like that landing spot for to us so
alright 13 the Cleveland Browns nothing
changes here with the Browns we need to
fix this offensive line we need to add
pieces to this offensive line I'm going
with Trey Adams now medically trained
atoms could be a day-to player when all
is said and done with some of the wear
and tear he's had over these last couple
years but talent wise to tackle as a run
blocker and as a pass protector he fits
everything the Cleveland Browns need and
would easily easily be a top 15 pick
here yeah Mahler he's just a mauler the
Raiders at number 14 is the pick they
got from the Chicago Bears
Isaiah Simmons somehow luckily falls
through this spot where he is
tailor-made to play linebacker for the
Oakland Raiders he could play inside
linebacker we know how well he covers
which is a huge need for this team
covering the middle of the field the
Raiders are one of the hottest teams in
football right now John Gruden's coaches
in his ass off the rookie class looks
amazing throw Isaiah Simmons in the mix
here with Johnathan Abram back next year
and my god this defense in the middle is
really really impressive that would be
the perfect piece to add to their
defense especially to get more speed 15
the Philadelphia Eagles speaking of a
team that needs more speed on defense I
got a little more pass-rush juice and it
can run pretty well for a big guy here
on the defensive line yeet or gross made
OC has been phenomenal this year really
just long strong plays the run really
well if you watch them against Indiana
this weekend you saw he had yet another
sack
he really does it all super high
character player that would fit what how
he was looking for here so you two are
gross meadows number 15 they're gonna
have to get a little younger on the edge
of their defensive line soon and I think
he would be the guy for that last pick
in the first half of the trap number 16
the Miami Dolphins this from the
Pittsburgh Steelers from Minka
Fitzpatrick I'm on AJ epinasty here they
need an outside pass rusher put him next
to Christian Wilkins and you have to
dynamic defensive lineman that you can
build around epinet can kick inside on
third downs the last several weeks he's
been playing exceptional folk
as Iowa has gotten rolling beating pin
state on Saturday a big day for the hawk
ice but man I just love what epinet has
brought to the table as a pass rusher 66
to 80 he brings versatility linked he's
got it all
we are back Connor you were back on the
clock number 17 the Tennessee Titans
take it away all right really no
surprise here I think that Titans are a
team that quarterback is gonna follow
the conversation with them
this entire draft cycle I'm going with
Jacob Eason big arm has some turnover
problems at times he's almost the anti
Mariota in this spot
I think the Titans will be looking for a
big play kind of guy in East and awhile
he still needs some developing to do and
it's gonna be a question of if he does
declare after all of this I think
Tennessee would be willing to take the
gamble in the second half of this first
round yeah i Eason is tough because it
does feel like he plays poorly in big
games I know he doesn't have them up the
most help around him
but I like to trace that of their number
18 the Carolina Panthers know
quarterbacks here to draft I do think
they would consider it would Cam Newton
likely gone Kyle Allen struggled
big-time on Sunday so the Panthers where
do they go
CJ Henderson fits what I believe they
want to do at the corner position he's
physically asked good size this is an on
paper need for them Henderson is someone
I like I would go safety here but grant
Delpit has disappointed me so much this
year that I can't justify drafting him
this early so Henderson instead at
corner James Bradbury is gonna be a free
agent be interesting to see what the
Panthers corners look like next year
well 19 for the Raiders I am gonna take
from that LSU secondary but it is not
gonna be grant dealt but it's gonna be a
steam eight Christian full and the
Raiders definitely need some more punch
at corner you got them Isaiah Simmons a
couple picks before this matte so if
they get Simmons and Fulton they can
cover tight ends they can cover running
back second cover wide receivers they
can run with anyone and play with little
attitude while doing it so adding those
two you guys would be a significant
boost to this Raiders defense yeah
defense looks a little different after
this draft which is what they need
number 20 the Jacksonville Jaguars this
pick from the LA Rams and I don't know
that the draft could fall worse for a
team just to be completely honest like I
don't know
where you go at this point this is a
reach I just wanna be clear that but
it's a need and I think if you're gonna
reach at a position offensive tackle is
a good one especially if you're reaching
on trace in Austin Jackson has good
athleticism good length he's physical he
plays with a mean streak he doesn't need
to develop a little bit and the USC
often says at times looked really good
and he's flourished at times they look
really bad so having good offensive
guards next to him will be key but I
think Austin Jackson has a future as a
left tackle in the NFL and that is a big
need for Jacksonville with Cam Robinson
just looking like he doesn't belong out
on the edge anymore 21 Dallas Cowboys
you know they're gonna need some help in
the secondary this offseason and I went
with someone that his stock has dropped
almost as much as anyone this year and
that's grant and help it because he's
simply not tackling anyone now Matt you
made the point that you saw her when
James do this at times in his final
season in college I think Delpit is a
better player than what he's showing
this year at LSU and I think if anyone
can get the best version of Grant's
outfit it's the Dallas Cowboys and this
defensive staff I really really do where
you might take him at 21 here if you're
Dallas and ended up getting a top 10
player in this trap I still like grant
help it there is no secret his stock has
fallen and he's got to get better but I
just think he's not leaving it all out
on the field this year yep that's
exactly how it looks to me like and I
said I've said it about Darwin James
when he came back from that injury it's
like oh man he might be saving himself a
little bit but he turned it on later in
the year we're still waiting for Grant
out but to do that to turn on later in
the year he's got some big games to do
that into a huge game so God please
grant wrap up tackle somebody buddy
number 22 the Indianapolis Colts weren't
a little bit of an LSU run here they
need youth on the outside I liked kamoko
Turei think he has a bright future but
they need more pass rushers Kayla van
chase Tom we've seen in a couple games
Alabama Florida he had his best games
against big teams I think he's coming
back from injury the rust is falling off
we're starting to see him play up to the
caliber that we expect we talked to
Jacob hester about him several weeks ago
or one week you up gosh that was a long
week
and everyone loves chase on they do
expect he's going to come out even as a
redshirt sophomore
rocking that number 18 but I like
chasing a lot I think he's gonna test
he's gonna interview well and Noah Chris
Ballard like we do he really fits what
they would like to have for the
Indianapolis Colts 23 Kansas City Chiefs
this is a defense that really really
needs to figure out how to stop the run
I think they need to figure out a lot of
things because if you can make this an
average unit this team will have a Super
Bowl shot every year with Pat mahomes at
quarterback I went with Dylan Moses and
this is another case of a team in the
second half of the draft in the second
half of the first round capitalizing on
a great prospect falling for different
reasons and for Moses said he didn't
play this year he got hurt he's expected
recover he's expected to be back I think
if you're the Chiefs this is the gamble
that you take because you can get a star
player in Moses this lay in the draft
yeah this is such such a need for them
anterior offensive line will be as well
free agency it's gonna be fascinating
for this team where they decide to spin
their resources number 20 for the
Minnesota Vikings davier Rhodes got
abused in the first half on Sunday I
think we're gonna see a big change at
corner for the Minnesota Vikings this
offseason Paul Senna Deebo can start
that a player we're gonna see Saturday
against Cal he has ball skills made last
year led college football passes
defensed he has sized a Deebo was close
to a total package I just need to see
how well he's gonna run before I
completely hitch my wagon to him as a
prospect but on paper everything is
there that you want he checks a lot of
boxes for me and he would fit that
Vikings defense yeah it's crazy to see
Rhodes at 29 fall off a cliff
like he has and they still owe him some
guaranteed monies that's gonna be a very
interesting decision at the end of the
year 25 Miami Dolphins you got yourself
a pretty good draft here you got
yourself a quarterback AJ epinet to rush
the passer now you go into Vaughn to
Smith this might be the best value you
pick at this point of the giraffe
because I think it's about the Smith has
the chance to be an upper tier wide
receiver a great fit in Miami with speed
reliable hands somebody like Chris Greer
and Brian Flores they'll really like the
mental makeup of a player like Smith so
this is a no-brainer for me at 25 we
gave him a quarterback earlier now you
give him a playmaker because they
drafted and they've tried to throw
assets at receivers and it just hasn't
happened so this is a big need for them
number 26 the Buffalo Bills t Higgins
they need a receiver who can extend his
case
Radiesse help Josh Allen out a little
bit that's what t Higgins does the best
he has long arms good size
he's been overshadowed a little bit and
I think Clemson is now being slept on
and it's a little bit criminal because
this team is playing really well t
Higgins is a huge part of that the bills
I mean it's almost like in black and
white they have to draft a receiver in
the first round t Higgins the best on
the board since you just stole Devon to
Smith yeah had to do that to you sorry
that's just the way it goes when we get
to this point in the drafts every man
for themselves 27 the Green Bay Packers
we've said it a lot on mock draft Monday
this is a team that would like to get
younger on the offensive line now when
you look at out the Jenkins
he's been phenomenal this year one of
the best rookies in the NFL this year
but he's only one man it's as simple as
that I went with someone that could
probably play tackle and guard and
that's Trey Smith from the Tennessee and
this team has changed their identity
they are not an Aaron Rodgers drop back
and throw the ball 55 times the game
anymore they are Aaron Jones feed him
Jamal Williams feed him
you get Trey Smith you could run behind
him all day every day this would be a
slam dunk for a very tough nasty Packers
team yeah completely different identity
it's fascinating
see how Seahawks are up next Jamie
clowny will be a free agent
Ezekiel ants there will be a free agent
one or both could be back but they need
to address the defensive end position
even after drafting LJ Collier in the
first round last year this is where I
think they could get a speed rush and
thrill Lewis who has great size six foot
five 255 pounds with a frame to add even
more weight he reminds me a lot of Frank
Clark at Michigan in terms of what type
of player he is
we know they liked Frank Clark a lot in
Seattle before he was traded to Kansas
City this is a scheme fit that works so
well in my opinion so if Terrell Lewis
again medicals would be big for him like
we've said with a couple guys because
he's been banged up a Bama but as long
as he checks all the boxes medically I
think Terrell Lewis could be a steal at
28 yeah I mean it's it's just ridiculous
what they have on that front
over there 29 the Baltimore Ravens we
made this pick in the last mock draft
Monday but me and Matt when we were
planning before the show right there's
nowhere else for them to go they're
playing too good right now to even find
it so Kenneth Murray get a little speed
at linebacker somebody that could
probably play every linebacker position
this Baltimore defense
is well coach they are fun to watch they
are talented in the secondary they are
getting the most out of everyone up
front you know what Lamar Jackson to
marking or we could do for that often so
Kenneth Murray just add another piece in
that front seven they've had a lot of
success with Oklahoma players there as
well you know my fears though that
they'll draft DeAndre Swift and no one
will ever be able to stop them
offensively oh my god that was playing
really well he looks fresh but God if
they got DeAndre swift yeah that would
suck right number 30 the New Orleans
Saints Mike Thomas is gonna catch 160
passes this year which is amazing I'm
very happy for Mike but they need
someone else in this offense to help
them do work yeah whoever this Drew
Brees Jake from Teddy Bridgewater
whoever's a quarterback next year
they're gonna need someone more to throw
to other than trick one Smith so I'm
gonna give them a little biscuit Shane
Hall I'm just having fun
daydreaming about all the ways that Sean
Payton and Pete Carmichael and the crew
there can incorporate ylvis' cachet all
into this offense look where they do a
Ted Ginn you know it's like a 22 year
old thicker version of Ted Ginn so it
would just be like this is one of those
Madden moves you pull off and you're
like I'm just gonna line you up a
running back in the slot out wide hell
you might play tight in a couple times
the game we're just gonna have fun with
you offensively look for matchups and
that's what they do so well in New
Orleans so maybe a little bit of a
luxury pick but I think wide receiver to
is a big need here
[ __ ] look what they do and taste some
Hill I mean if you think back I can
catch touchdowns Leviticus Chanel could
do anything over there 31 New England
Patriots once again another repeat pick
but I'm just in love with the fit and if
you watch this New England they're
winning they're constantly winning they
lost one game this year they're just not
getting a ton from the tight end
position they're really not you could
see Tom Brady misses that hunter Bryant
compare him to Evan Engram I mean he's a
hybrid tight end he plays with great
speed he's great after the catch you can
move him around I think this would be
the perfect landing spot for him but
also just a great gift for the Patriots
and somebody they would know how to turn
into a near thousand yard kind of player
at that position yeah he's an athlete
for sure he's gonna be fun to watch him
over the course of the process last pick
number 32 the San Francisco 49ers they
need safety help Xavier McKinney from
Alabama
falls right into the laps here he could
play free safety right away I know John
Lynch is
not like straight come out said that he
doesn't value the safety position but it
seems like they have not evaluated it as
an early selection I think we see that
change of Xavier McKinney's on the board
alright Matt had to run but we are still
gonna knock out draft on draft here a
little solo edition of draft on draft
here in this first one from Garrett
Greenlee the Bengals haven't won a game
since Marvin Lewis was fired so are we
really sure they should have fired him
so number one yes it was time to move on
from Marvin Lewis I think the problem is
a lot of people need to realize that one
this franchise really needed to reset
and I don't know if Zac Taylor was the
right guy for the job and I when I say
that I mean I truly don't know it's
gonna take a while to figure that out
because this is a roster that needs to
be overturned as we always say on the
show the bengals scouting department is
one of the smaller ones in the NFL where
the coach has such a big influence over
the picks marvin lewis was picking the
players for many many years there where
and i hate using that excuse as oh well
it wasn't his roster but zach taylor's
got to get some players in there he's
got to get his franchise quarterback
listen I it was an interesting hire it
was a bold hire it seemed like it came
out of nowhere but that doesn't mean
that firing Marvin Lewis was a mistake
because this is a team that was treading
water for years year after year after
year so I think when you look at the
situation willing to take a risk to move
on for a bigger ceiling is always worth
it you know it just always comes down to
being worth it now if you made the wrong
choice you made the wrong choice and you
try again but I don't think this bengals
team would have ever won a Super Bowl or
made it far in the playoffs of Marvin
Lewis and it was simply the perfect time
to move on but it's a great point at
some point Zac Taylor's got to win some
football games it doesn't matter you
have to what they didn't expect to to
have this kind of season this year it is
without a doubt a disappointment he
won't be a one-and-done that would shock
me the bengals are often a cheap team
anyway but i think when you look at it
he's it's got to be put up or shut up
and you have to win some football games
you can't Hugh Jackson this thing over
in Cincinnati
alright number two here on the draft on
draft list from Jacob DeLong who said
the best giraffe class so far this
season my boat is definitely Oakland
Cleveland Farrell starting to come on
Josh Jacob spry Offensive Rookie of the
Year max Crosby is Abby's and Moreau and
Renfro looked great it's a shame that
Abram got hurt week 1 game 1 and it's
hard to disagree in terms of overall
impact of the depth of the class when
you look at Oakland I was actually
shocked when so many people I remember
after round one did not like the Oakland
class and I think it was either me or
mattre both of us picked them as a
winner at the end of the bleacher report
traffic coverage when we shoot our
videos for the Bleacher Report app and
you go on Twitter it's been a long night
you haven't seen anyone's reactions and
people were just did not like a lot of
the pics from Oakland and I think where
they were wrong was they took high
character instant impact players that
fit the system and I know Farrell a lot
of people were disappointing that as a
start he's looked a lot better lately
and he'll be a really good player for a
long time Josh Jacobs has the chance to
be one of the best running backs in the
league for a while now taking our first
round running back is always
controversial but at least they hit on
the player where he's been a star for
them so far and once again when you look
at Jonathan Abram you know he would have
been a great player this year so shame
he got hurt now the injuries were a
problem in college where you could sit
there and say it probably was a little
early to take him there because you have
those injury risks but he'll come back
strong he'll be ready to go but the
value is where I really look at why this
class is a winner you know anybody could
have taken Cleon Farrell in the top ten
anyone could have taken Jonathan Abram
or Josh Jacobsen round one because those
guys weren't round 1 lakhs necessary
they were good players but they weren't
lakhs we were sweating that they'd be
off the board but where do they really
win here is the value they've gotten in
this class with Crosby being a later
round pick Foster Murrow being a later
round pick hunter Renfro everybody loves
hunter Renfro and then he sits on the
board for hours they were four days so I
think Oakland's done a really good job
mike Mayock done a really good job
because Jon Gruden was clearly
struggling as a drafter without mike
Mayock he needed someone in there that
can handle the person
outside of things and I think it's gonna
make teams reevaluate their hiring
process in the scouting Department where
you don't need to just go through
traditional Scouts over and over again
mike Mayock did not have experience
doing this in an NFL front office before
taking this GM job and he's thrived
he really has thrived and it's gonna be
very interesting to see if this opens
the door for more media personalities
maybe analytics people to really get
into higher decision-making level jobs
all right next up from Roman Thomas off
is it time for the Vikings to move on
from Xavier roads if they do would it be
better for them to trap someone early or
try to patch that hole in free agency so
during the mock draft Matt did a really
good job covering this to answer your
question quite simply the answer is yes
they need to and the draft pick at 24
since it was later in the round a lot of
the top corners are gone was Paulson
daddybo from Stanford somebody that
we're gonna get to see up close and
personal this weekend against Cal which
will be really fun I think when you look
at Rhodes it's fascinating to see a guy
fall off a cliff like this at age 29 now
you look at the contract they're not out
free next year they could still cut them
if they want when you look at the
breakdown they'll save 8.1 million if
they cut them they'll have they'll be on
the hook for almost 5 million in dead
money next year and they'd even have
some dead money if they kept them and
cut them in 2021 so it's gonna cost them
a little bit but the savings they get in
return might be worth it because Rhodes
is just I mean he's really fallen off
it's crazy when you see this kind of
play and it's almost the Achilles heel
of this Vikings defense that has been a
top unit for a while now and for Rhodes
who was drafted in 2013 you thought that
you know usually corners fall off that
cliff on the wrong side of 30 so this is
a little early for him and it's not like
he was a guy with a slow 40 I mean he
ran a 4 for 3 at the combine so you know
some of these corners that you saw it
which remain Johnson shermaine Johnson
was a four six a four six kind of runner
maybe even a little slower coming out of
college and he had some good years but
he fell off a cliff really early because
he doesn't trust his legs anymore
with roads it's just shocking to see it
come down to this and for the Vikings
it's gonna make for a tough decision but
it is clearly a group a position group
that they have to upgrade all right last
one for draft on draft of the day Thomas
Burton who is the best talent developer
in college which coach do you trust the
most to have his players ready for the
NFL Nick Saban you know for Dabo though
you could list on and on I think we
could all talk about those guys and we
could talk about Ohio State the job that
they do with their defensive linemen
every year is a one Ryan day is great
with quarterbacks Lincoln Reilly's great
with quarterbacks those schools get the
most out of their running backs wide
receiver receivers even their offensive
lineman Alabama develops NFL players LSU
develops NFL players non-stop same with
Clemson I think where it gets lost is
somebody like Chris Peterson at
Washington when you look at what he does
with his defensive backs group every
year is really special and Washington is
a team that they have offensive linemen
that will go into the NFL this year they
have a tight end that'll go into the NFL
this year they have a quarterback that
will probably go into the NFL this year
if he wants to a couple of defensive
backs they always have good defensive
linemen good linebackers I think
Washington quietly has become an NFL
talent developing pool all those coaches
and and Peterson has been doing this for
a while I mean he was doing it before
Washington that's what's special about
him and his assistants but all those top
schools it's a no-brainer that they're
the best at it but I think you're
looking for the underrated groups that's
definitely one obviously Penn State puts
players into the NFL you know it's
Oklahoma though is the one where you
look at somebody doing it at a rate of
what are they when they get to the
University versus what are they when
they go into the draft that's the most
impressive one to me because Lincoln
Riley will take what are considered
failures Baker Mayfield had to transfer
because he wasn't wanted anymore Kyler's
Murray couldn't win a starting job
places and wasn't wanted anymore and
what goes to oh you Baker goes to oh you
those guys become number one overall
picks now you see Jalen Hertz
Alabama wanted him to play a running
back
and Jalen Hertz coming into the season
was maybe gets drafted as a day three
quarterback or switches positions now
the conversation around Jalen Hurd it's
the same probably go around to as a
quarterback not even not even a question
of is does he have to switch positions
he'll play quarterback so I think what
it goes by position by position school
by school and a difference of how much
developing they're doing but what
Lincoln can do from when he gets a
player from the first month are on
campus to the end of their first season
is truly incredible it really is and
that's why he's he's one of those guys
that the NFL is gonna come calling if he
wants to we'll see if he leaves if not
Oklahoma's gonna have to pay him a
truckload of money alright that's our
show today hope everyone enjoyed the
mock draft as always give us our
feedback of our picks if you loved it if
you hate it reminder this weekend we
will be at Stanford for the Cal game
matt has posted everything I've posted
everything it's on the stick the flow
I'll count the map of where we'll be at
in the tailgate section with the
tailgate guys it's gonna be a blast you
don't want to miss it and we'll catch
you guys for the midweek show on
Wednesday